Yasuho works as a delivery person at Sagawa Express,...
...one of the largest transportation companies in Japan...
...with more than 50,000 employees spread across 400 offices throughout the country.
Oh, she's changed into her Sagawa uniform, looking sharp.
Okay, she's eating a chocolate chip cookie for breakfast.
Pocari sweat is a popular sports drink in Japan.
This is the go-to drink when Japanese want to quickly get hydrated.
So, this is the main Sagawa shipping terminal in the Tokyo area...
...and where all shipments are sorted every morning.
She needs to pick up the boxes which go to our specific delivery area..
...and load them into her micro van.